[Music]
hey everybody welcome to a very special
edition of nintendo treehouse live for
splatoon 3. i am demetrius and i'm here
joined by taryn and our own treehouse
squid research lab
dutch
[Laughter]
all right so what do we have for you
today well we got some really cool stuff
we wanted to show you today was a little
bit of what splatoon 3 is about
including the actual single player story
so we're gonna
start off with a single player deep dive
and then kind of show you some come back
and show you some new weapons stages and
strategies
for those who have never actually heard
of splatoon 3 before it's a team-based
action game or multiplayer game with
also single player story mode which
you're seeing today
so what you're seeing right in front of
you actually is the world
of alterna
i'm sorry we were supposed to ooh
weren't we in unison
[Laughter]
dutch
[Laughter]
sorry we're silly we're having a good
time here all right so i am in control
of agent 3 and i have a weapon that can
use ink so for those who have never seen
a splatoon before
for splatoon 3 and other games in the
series you can actually swim in your own
ink
and refill and do many other great
things with it it's it's really really
great so we call this right here swim
form and this is kit farm and you can
use the kit form to ink many different
things which is going to come in very
very handy
what we'll show you soon
one of the things to note is
um you really don't need experience to
play single player so one if you're
worried about you know hey this is
splatoon 3. uh do i have to worry about
you know playing the other two games you
don't have to it's okay it's okay it's
okay this game has a great story though
and it'll have the same kind of feel
between those who have played splatoon 2
before or even the uh octo expansion
which was uh the nso expansion pack you
can get right now
all right so
uh one thing i want to point out uh for
this story is you see right here this is
fuzzy ooze you actually want to be
careful oh my gosh what are you doing
you do that on purpose
so fuzzy ooze bad
something's going on here nothing's not
right so there's a big mystery going on
with the fuzzy use we want to kind of
like you know see what's going on with
alternate how is this happening we
really want to you know really find out
okay so with that in mind
are some other additional things we'll
kind of go over as we play through these
stages um such as like you know the
little hidden secrets this little guy
here called small fry
and some other little things but first
what i'm gonna do is i'm actually gonna
pass this controller over to 10 to me
thank you
and we're going to actually go to a
stage called twirling swirling and
whirling and just allow us to get that
set up one moment there here we go and
to be clear you're playing as agent
three but this is not the agent three
you know this is a new agent three so
don't worry the other one is still
around um
but this is a new one just spoilers
spoilers
no there's no spoilers i'm just no
spoilers
okay so what you'll see right here is
taran actually has three different
choices uh we're gonna have her start
with the hero gear to begin with yeah so
you have recommendations too you can see
it says try this so again we're gonna do
this mostly because i love small fry and
i want to show you small fry very badly
and you can see other information on the
screen like on the top right it shows
you how many tries you have so i have
just three
that should be fine i'm new to splatoon
but i should be able to handle it i've
got small features
speaking of which too like i said before
this is a great entry point as well
story mode in particular so this is
perfect for you yeah yeah so if i don't
want to jump into multiplayer right away
i can do story mode first and it's a
great place to practice or just play
with smaller i also like that so i'm
showing off here what you can do with it
you can throw it
don't feel bad it can handle itself
and then you can call it back with the
this way which is a function that you
have in multiplayer as well right
yeah
all right so you got three attempts on
the board
and here you want it kind of like it
says to navigate to the rotating area
oh look at that perfect throw nice
sounds so surprised and i'm a little
offended
not at all okay well look at this
look at this look look wait wait
wait wait wait wait
[Music]
that was a trick that i learned just for
you guys
i didn't even know what that's actually
really cool that's the pacifist approach
right there
just allow themselves to destroy them
so you saw that i threw small fry in the
beginning i'm gonna throw it again
but for a different purpose this time
because this is an armored enemy and i'm
scared of it and it can definitely splat
me so i'm using small fry to distract it
and then i turn around and spot it from
behind also like a rat i just let stuff
fall off the edges
get splatted and distracted that's how i
play i guess one thing you'll know too
is that taran is swimming in her own ink
if there's enemy ink which is purple
it's not too good for you oh my gosh
we're gonna pretend that didn't happen
i have three tries good you're good
i'm playing with motion controls right
now you can turn that off or just change
the sensitivity um but there is an
advantage to using them so by all means
play however you prefer to play yeah
once i got the hang of motion controls i
can't go back i love them go back agreed
same for me it took a little bit but i
really like him
so you see that small fry actually does
damage as well so you can use it to
distract uh and then like with the first
enemy you just throw it right in their
face
uh and they will take care well it will
take care of business
that you can shoot from here
and take out some of these little oh
look at you go
that is awesome okay well i was hoping
to get a sniper but i got a little too
greedy so now we're gonna have to deal
with both snipers so what i picked up
was a trisuka you get canned specials
you'll learn a little bit more about
specials in the next segment um but you
get them that way
in story mode and usually they're like
perfectly situated for whatever you have
to do so exactly that like if you're
looking at octo snipers in the face and
they're just
ready to splat you
uh
that trizuca was perfect for countering
it and it's actually the same specials
that you'd find in the multiplayer mode
as well so it's good a good chance to
kind of get familiar with them and maybe
practice a little bit yes get i heard
the word practice and i nod and agree
practicing is good i could use more of
it but it's super fun like even if you
get spotted or fall off spontaneously
for
literally no apparent reason uh it's
still a good time
and i love that about splatoon it just
keeps this like tone of like chaos and
fun and like doing it your own way and
like i'm all about that
even if i fall off the edge
okay so i'm at the end i've also been
known to fall
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't know
you manifested it i manifested it i'm
not gonna jump for that now i'm
the first time you afraid this take our
time well the thing is good too is that
the items up there respawning what
you're going to be picking up is some
armor which helps
oh yes thank you for munching that
demetrius yeah you pick up armor
ouch a good example of the armor
thank you oh yeah if i didn't have that
armor i'd probably be in trouble please
no please no you got this you got this
just stay there for a second let
yourself recharge you got it yeah so
there's like a whole
stealth mode
and you do this in multiplayer too if
you move super fast people can see you
under the ink
and if you move slower they can't see
you so just like in story mode if you
get good at being sneaky
uh your chances of success increase
significantly i'm very sneaky i must say
that was great
okay guys
guys
guys
[Applause]
oh i've got a i've got another ready
ready there you go yes there we go
okay
complete and we're done with that
mission we did it
no i took two
unnecessary first time clear bonus three
minutes 13 seconds that looks great well
that's right and there's a timing
mechanic i'll hand this back to you
so there's a bunch of replayability with
these missions
you can choose different weapons like we
showed you earlier so you can challenge
yourself with maybe weapons that aren't
so well suited and then you can also
time yourself so i'm sure my time for
that one was probably not amazing so i
could go back in and like play it over
and over again and try to get a better
time um and just get better that's a
great replayability for sure okay my
turn
all right demetrius you have to fall at
least twice
[Laughter]
we should also say that a lot of the
lore actually plays out through these
single-player
missions yeah find you know maybe hidden
objects here they're get they give you
kind of clues into
the world that we're in and and the
events yeah the sunken sea scrolls you
can find them out while you're playing
outside of the stages and they provide a
lot of background alert the lore is
really cool and this whole series that's
really cool laura
um all right so
i am doing stamp a mount i am going to
be using one of the new weapons the
splatana stamper with curling bomb
see it matrix the switzana stamper or
splatano class of weapons are brand new
that they have like a swipe when i just
use the attack button and if you hold
down the button you can charge up as a
charge slash
now the stamper itself outside of having
that really cool sound
it's more the heavier style of splatonic
class so you're going to see like the
the amount of ink i'm slinging from like
the ink blade is going to be a bit more
it's really great um one thing to note
is you kind of like long range right and
then you have the short range if i'm up
close and i hit someone with this it's
gonna be pretty much a guaranteed splat
i've never noticed that but do you see
small fry was in the corner just like
looking at you with these big eyes like
why aren't you taking me with you
oh i missed that ah
it's just a little sad it's all right
also note that when i'm picking up our
power eggs and these can be used to
unlock certain things
see this is a perfect example this guy
has a shield which is going to be hard
but if i charge it up
how satisfying was that on a scale of
one to ten great
ten out of ten ooh
gotcha that one was surprised
you didn't give that one a fair chance
the fight back i don't think i love how
i can just use this to like hit two
people at once it's so cool yeah i'm
really excited to see what people are
gonna do with this one in multiplayer
because it's kind of a combination you
know you have that longer range a little
bit weaker one
and then you have the kind of one-hit
splat charge one
that you can do from short range
yeah i think people are gonna have a lot
of fun i mean all weapons have different
styles and stuff but this one for me it
just i really like them you're gonna
play this with us yeah that's cool
i was trying i was trying to be a little
fancy there i'm just going to go across
this time come on come on come on there
we go
all right remember you have to fall off
at least twice
[Laughter]
there it is
this next part right here is a little
tough because there's this
guy on top and i have to kind of knock
all these down without him getting to oh
my
there we go
i think i got the guy behind him too
i feel like you've already mastered this
platano and we should all be very afraid
this is a really fun weapon i gotta be
careful with this guy
there we go
okay and now your favorite part oh is
this it this is the part
for those who are wondering why they're
teasing me it's because this part
of the battle
i kind of let them come oh my gosh
[Music]
yes but there's like three of them right
there
so these are octolings they're a
different type of enemy that function
like a little bit more like a player
might you could say and so of course
they're a little bit more difficult but
not difficult for demetrius all right i
hope the camera was i mean i had such
gamer face right there
oh 2 39. i'll take it all right i'll
take it i'll take it that was pretty
good
all right you are not stressed don't
even give up you're too good at that
all right
yeah let me pass this over to touch we
saved the hardest one for dutch he's in
the lab coat so he's obligated
this is the fun part
so the next one that we have coming up
is called one-way ride through target
town
and we're gonna have dutch use the
tri-stringer
yeah let's do it
he has other options which you'll see
and those are a little bit easier but no
we don't let dutch do the easy ones
yeah i'm both i'm both excited and
nervous to try this one out this is a
brand new weapon class in splatoon 3.
and let's take a look at it here
so you can see it's kind of like a like
a bow basically
and so
the way it works is if i tap the attack
button then you can see it shoots three
little projectiles like that if i hold
it down and charge it up
you can see they stick to whatever
surface they hit and you get kind of a
secondary little explosion that'll do a
little bit of damage
and then if i charge it up even more
then you get kind of a tight grouping
that goes a little bit farther
and you still get that uh that second
little pop
it's hard to survive if you get hit with
all three right directions yeah i
imagine it's really good there's a
vertical shot too is there not yeah
it's kind of like a roller where uh for
those of you who have played splatoon uh
games before so if i jump and shoot
then i get
a vertical shot so if i charge that up
as
well can see the shots line up
vertically
this feels like a skilled player's
weapon yeah i'm i'm pretty good it's
kind of like it's got good range it's
got good coverage it's got good damage i
think it's it'll be really interesting
to see what people do with this one as
well yeah i really this is another
really fun weapon to use for sure
all right let's see it dodge no time
no more delays
one thing to note as dutch goes through
too for people watching home you
actually don't have to finish all the
stages to get through story mode but
there are a lot of fun things to play
yeah this one's challenging but
that's a good thing and you don't have
to do it if you do yeah this is a really
fun challenging one all right so i just
broke those targets and that activated
the ride rail down here and the thing
about the ride rail is it's like the
title says it's a one-way ticket so i'm
gonna be riding this thing there's no
turning back and if i don't break all
the targets on a given section then i'm
gonna run out of track no pressure
so let's do it at least two falls
remember
we've got a lot of opportunity here but
we're giving dutch three chances
you're wearing that kofi using dutch
i have face and doctor dutch
one thing to note soon i apologize dutch
didn't point this out but
as you turn into swim form you do
actually recharge your enemy in just a
minute
music's so good it is good well the
visuals are so nice like this stage in
particular is so chaotic that like you
don't really get a chance to look like
you got it oh my
[Laughter]
it was
but the visuals are so nice like if you
get a chance to look up it's like an
inverted cityscape but i'm busy i know
i'm so sorry i'm not asking you too
continue with your research
all right all right here's a good spot
look up at that yeah that looks oh thank
you oh my gosh it's okay dutch
that explosion we're all like we can
hear us getting quiet because there's
all right then i'm going to use that
kind of secondary
there we go
you have to be careful jumping between
the rails too
yes we've learned that
perfect there we go one thing you're
seeing dutch do right now is he's
actually aiming for those power eggs
because it's kind of a good hint or a
tip of where you want to shoot with this
weapon it's like right in the middle
next it's got that explosive effect
things are looking my gosh
i got this this next upcoming part yeah
this upcoming part right here is pretty
difficult as you can see there's a lot
so dutch is going to want to try to slow
down and i'm just going to take out his
manny oh
god did it oh my gosh she's going to do
it
no pressure everything is fine okay
don't forget to go through there you go
yeah i've definitely hit those grates
before i like
landed a perfect shot and then just get
bopped off because we're crazy
it doesn't feel this one's a little
tricky too because you can see it on
different sides you have to charge
pretty fast oh my gosh all right here we
go i'm gonna do it in two tries ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
did you get it i didn't get it no
okay but that was too full so now you
can get it
i have clearance you have my
i've seen dutch do this several times
successfully so yeah he's got it
even if he doesn't do it this time know
that he can and it's extremely
impressive this is the one this is the
one
it's fun though now i want to be like
all right okay is it my turn let me try
and challenge you right now
i haven't been able to beat it yet did
you feed it with a try stringer yet i
have oh you did it took some time still
but it was fun not trying it out
all right you got it cool
okay so now we got these again all right
i think it's
those two right there make me the most
nervous ready to mess up on those too
yeah because you kind of have to lead
your shot right you have to kind of
think in advance all right i'm going to
shoot and then they'll explode then i'll
be okay
i love these stages though for getting a
feel
for oh
no just jump off let's have you try one
more time just jump off one more time
like the rest
can you jump up there you go yeah all
right we'll do one more let's do you're
giving him a fourth i am oh my goodness
i'm a good friend like that i got the
back dutch
but if he fails this fourth one
though that we just have you have to
move then the people are gonna have to
see it for themselves yeah
i love these single-player missions to
kind of get a feel for each weapon
kind of see how they behave get some
ideas for how you might use it in
multiplayer
and this isn't the only rail grinding
mission but it's
one of the more challenging ones so
don't worry it's a difficult one but
also know that you know by the time you
get to this it'll you'll have a solid
grass
oh okay i love those rings every time it
feels like a reward getting to jump
through them delicious
get hungry
okay we got it all right see looking
good looking good looking good
don't chase it i think i drink that last
time no
no
oh
[Music]
i think that's good enough for me yeah
you have to let people try this one on
their own at home thanks for trying that
though guys that was awesome that was
that was great thank you for tasting it
so
that's for us is gonna be it for uh for
this part uh just note uh that we
actually will be coming back um with
some you know kind of a strategy segment
on uh what you can do uh in the game
itself
so stick stick around we'll be right
back and as always though thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
the splatoon 3 enter the splatlands
invitational 2022 tournament
this event will take place on september
5th at pax west
some of the top finishers from this
summer splatoon 2 inkopolis showdown
will head to seattle and compete in
north america's first ever splatoon 3
invitational
[Music]
follow the official nintendo vs twitter
account for updates
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to a very
special edition of nintendo treehouse
live featuring splatoon 3. they want to
do that
all right and i'm here with taryn
and our very own treehouse squid lab
researcher
dutch
all right
so what we're going to do now is we
actually wanted to show off some of our
multiplayer stuff now before we start i
just wanted to do a little bit of a
housekeeping just let everybody know
that this is a special build that we're
playing on we're actually not going to
get right into
multiplayer but we did want to show you
some elements to focus on that because
there's a lot of really great stuff
and again just to let everybody know
this game is coming out on september 9th
so just a little thing to keep in mind
all right now
so splatoon 3
let's see what we got first i think
we're going to show off a splash o-matic
so dutch yeah let's see it is a
splash-o-matic so the splash-o-matic is
in the shooter class of weapons which is
kind of it's kind of like the bread and
butter of the splatoon series it's like
your well-rounded
versatile weapon you can see it's just
got a classic rapid fire it's got decent
range
you're pretty much gonna be able to do
it all with this weapon
uh and we should also mention that
weapons come in sets in splatoon so you
can kind of see in the upper right hand
corner uh i have a
sub weapon as well in this case that's
the burst bombs it looks like this and
throw that against the wall there so you
can see it just kind of
explodes on impact which is great it's
probably my favorite sub it's really
easy is it yeah i like the autos because
they just find i guess we'll see that
soon no spoilers but they find your
enemy so you don't have to
and the most exciting thing about this
set for me is the crab tank uh we can
see that's my special weapon in that
upper right hand corner is kind of
shimmering there so that means
it's ready to go so let's take a look
here it is
this looks so good
it's so dangerous
love that one and actually i'm gonna go
ahead and clean up here i can get that
again because the crab tank actually has
two
different attacks so that was the first
one that's kind of like a rapid fire
machine gun that really has very good
range as well
uh and then there's another attack
it's kind of like this big shell that
has an area of effect here great area
effect that i really like using that one
a lot
one thing to know too to point out for
those who are watching at home is we're
actually in the new multiplayer lobby uh
this is the test range side of things so
if you're wondering like whoa what is
this this is a brand new
brand new feature to use splatoon 3.
it's really really cool it allows you to
well test your weapons in the range
yeah it's actually fun and it is a big
change from splatoon 2 where now the
lobby is like a physical space where you
can be
uh practicing while you're waiting for a
match or i think we saw in the direct
that you'll see kind of holographic
ghosts of your friends in the lobby
they're online it's kind of a cool new
hub for the multiplayer battles let's
take a look around kind of see this
space here it looks so good
actually we we haven't showed off the
squid surge and roll which is something
we might want to do ah yeah
and that is a fun new addition to uh
splatoon 3 as well
and to show that off let's see so
the squid roll uh typically you know if
you're going in one direction
you get kind of a you have to slow down
and kind of stop your momentum to get
going in the other direction but with
this new mechanic here
you can turn
on the dime
and go in the opposite direction so
imagine maybe somebody's throwing a bomb
in front of you
uh you can change direction really
quickly and it actually gives you a few
frames of protection while you're doing
that move all right
let's let's see this in action all right
yeah so here's another
here's another toy that we've got in the
lobby over here uh which is the copy
machine so i'm going to go ahead and
wake it up here it's kind of vaguely
threatening
so the copy machine here does
it copies what i'm doing so
if i shoot it shoots
uh
it throws bombs when i throw bombs and
it tries to deflect blame on his
teammates if i try to deflect blame on
my teammates
does everything that i do dutch when
have you ever had to deflect a plane
let's [ __ ] that tough match
all right so i'm gonna try to show off
this uh new squid roll move that gives
you that uh that couple frames of
protection here so
i'm rolling wrong i see a bomb there you
go oh well done that is not easy right
there got it in one but kind of and you
kind of hear that like little like
shimmery kind of sound that lets you
know that you kind of got another let's
try one more
all right so then what since we look at
you show off
[Laughter]
so maybe we should move on to the next
topic here
oh actually you show off a squid search
yeah third that's another new uh
mechanic for splatoon 3's and that's
gonna help you get up walls so if i get
onto this wall and i charge it up it's
gonna shoot me up and give me a little
boost up there so i can kind of get the
drop on people so that's useful if
you're
maybe you've got somebody camping out up
here
you can come up here
see a little squid surge
and come down on it from above
you're so accurate
i tried practicing that a couple of
times i really love the movement it's
and that's the worst when you're like
set up the move perfectly and then you
get to the up to the top there and
you're like oh i missed it that's just
gonna be so much more ugly
anyway okay well uh let's check out
let's check out a different weapon yeah
yeah i was gonna say let's check out the
next one which i believe is one of your
favorites it is yeah i have spent a lot
of time with the carbon roller here and
actually while we're here i just want to
show off one more kind of quality of
life
improvement here you can sort uh the
weapons by class and you've got that up
here uh which is so good i love how they
added that yeah all right so i'm gonna
go ahead and clean up here so we get
some new
new territory here
so this is the carbon roller this is a
weapon in the roller class and the way
this class works is you've got a an ink
roller here
and if you press the attack button it
does kind of a horizontal
splash like that it's pretty short range
but it's pretty powerful as well
and if you hold it down
then you can run around with it on the
ground and mow people over that's great
and this particular one with most roller
weapons that's going to be a one a one
hit splat if you've got it rolling
around on the ground
uh but this one trades a little bit of
power for greater mobility which i love
because for for me my play style is
really like getting up in people's faces
smashing them and
look at them
people's faces duchess speaking of
mobility too the this one actually comes
with a zip caster which that's true yeah
and one well one more point on the uh
the roller class so you also have this
if you jump and attack then you do kind
of a vertical fling that gives you a
little bit more range
but it's a narrower
spread of ink so you kind of have to be
a little more accurate with it but yeah
so let's check out the zip caster here
which is a brand new special for
splatoon 3. uh and i'm really excited
about this one as somebody who spends a
lot of time with a roller which is short
range and you know kind of get pinned
down by people with longer range weapons
a lot so let's imagine maybe up on that
tower there there's somebody with a long
range weapon kind of pinning me down
back here
what the zip cast is going to do is
going to let me
zip around cling to walls
and it's gonna let me come up right on
this person
right there so good
and you do have to be careful when you
use it though because uh you might have
seen there there's a little bit a little
marker
and when it ends it sends you back to
the place you started so if you don't
take care of business with it and people
see where you're going to land they're
going to come right there and and be
waiting for it spot you yeah you'll land
and be like oh that was not what i was
expecting
uh and the sub weapon for this one as
well which we should you can see here
there's another one coming back from
splatoon 2 2 is the auto bomb
and that one
you can kind of see the little ring
shoots out when it lands and that's
going to detect the nearest enemy walk
over to it and explode
it's so awful i mean in the best
possible way you're the one throwing it
it's just brilliant all right so let's
show this off in our uh first stage we
wanted a display yeah let's take a look
so let's go ahead and cut away to that
and then we're going to go to
our first stage that we want to shoot
and we've got the splatoon 3 splatfest
world premiere coming up this weekend uh
so we wanted to take a look at some of
the stages that will be in the rotation
and if you've never heard of splatfest
before it's it's a mode where you play
turf four and try color turf four but
first you actually get to vote on three
different uh choices
depending if in this case you want to be
rock paper or scissors
i think i'm gonna go for scissors no
wait i'm paper now i'm scissors we've
had this discussion
that's all i know i'm wrong
we're going to be on the same team i
guess that could be fun too
i'd rather not get spotted by you a spot
with you so like it's actually a really
good point too i'm glad you brought that
up turned too it's just for those who
who don't know at home you definitely
want to vote for the same thing if you
won't be on the same team just a little
good point
all right so here we are in scorch gorge
so take it away dutch yeah so it's kind
of you know it's kind of
i'm really looking forward to this this
weekend because this is kind of eerie
right here it's like there's nobody here
this is deserted i'm excited to see some
people get in here and uh play around
so this is uh kind of keeping in the
theme with splatoon 3 which is chaos
right so we've got this kind of
gritty rusted out worn down rugged
terrain here
and uh
a couple of jellyfishes out there casual
jellies
on the rocks kind of a canyon
that feels like a desert yeah
either way
and then i'll go ahead and open up the
turf map here so you can see the layout
of the of the stage
and so i'm thinking that for this
particular stage it's all going to be
about this middle
tower here because that controls the
access to each side so that's that's the
only way you're going to get into the
other team's base so let's come up here
yeah which is dutch's favorite thing
sorry
it's all about i think defending this
middle and keeping it controlled right
so if you want to get into the other
base you're going to have to come up
here and go along this catwalk which
leaves you kind of exposed from below if
you go into squid form you see drop
right through it
yes well there we go
and then once you're over here then you
can get back this this way and cause
trouble
but now now that you have the zip caster
though yeah
so for
uh i think the zip tracker is gonna be
great for maybe taking control of that
middle area so you can see
uh
you know imagine somebody's controlling
that and
dominating you from the center post
there so what are we going to do let's
get the zip caster here and fly right
over here come out this way
attaches to surfaces that you wouldn't
normally be able to ink correct did we
already correct that that's a great one
so powerful it's it's really really
great it's it's all about kind of moving
in a triangle
moment
[Laughter]
and being able to stick to every surface
really lets you kind of
zip around the stage and uh get behind
enemy lines
i imagine being unpleasantly surprised
by thinking you're safe in one area and
then dutch comes winging in with his
carbon roller
and of course there are many other
specials that you'll be special weapons
that you'll get using you know depending
on the weapons that you have but yeah
let's hop back and take a look at a
couple other
couple other sets here so let's look at
sports gorge which is going to be in the
rotation
uh this weekend
and
let's hop back in
okay
so time to show off something a little
different yeah so you're taking a look
at a shooter class weapon the
splash-o-matic that was the first one we
saw and we saw the carbon roller uh in
the roller class
let's take another look at
splat charge the splat chart matrix's
favorite right i'm just kidding
i really like this weapon i think it's
great fun i'm just
not the best at it
so this is your classic long-range kind
of sniper style weapon
you can see the range on this one
compared to the other ones
that char drop is so satisfying yeah and
that sound that it makes so this is what
it sounds like normally if you're
missing but
i feel targeted by that comment
it's cool though i always appreciated
seeing someone on my team using this
weapon and i'm always just in awe and
when you get a good charger on your team
it is it's like a relief because this
this is really for like the crafty
skilled patient
backline style player uh uh
hang out in the back and just just take
people down and help defend
what's the sub and special for this yeah
so the sub for this one is the splat
bomb uh which
kind of this pyramid shaped one uh you
throw it out and after it settles on the
ground for like a second it'll explode
and then oh let's go back to the copy
machine and i can show off the special
here so this is another special that's
brand new for splatoon 3. this is so
good this is probably my personal
favorite over the craft tank
the crap
great but this is so good i think it's
going to catch a lot of people off guard
with that's not an ink you can use if
you if you use it correctly
all right so this is the ink vac and
what it's going to do is basically suck
up any ink that's being fired at me and
then i can shoot it back and it'll
create a big uh a big explosion so this
is sucking up all the ink that the copy
machine is shooting i'm going to launch
it back that way
you can see the range on this it's so
good
you know i shot that from like back here
it goes all the way basically all the
way across the test range here
um you should
try that one more time maybe we should
show that without uh powering it up just
to kind of give people an idea of what
it's like
yeah it looks good there we go
and did we explain just in case somebody
knows what dutch is doing right now is
he's actually inking the ground so he's
building up his special meter that you
see in the top right hand screen exactly
so just for those who are new are
wondering why is he doing that oh you're
just randomly firing on the ground
i'm sucking up all that ink
so i'm not you know i'm not getting
damaged by it it's kind of absorbing it
but if you keep getting hit after it's
full that will take you out so you have
to be careful when you're timing it so
don't let the coffee machine splat you
it wasn't sure he was gonna do it
it's looking a little bit dicey there
for a second another thing that's back
from splatoon 2 is
storing your charge
and then you can swim in the ink for a
couple seconds
before uh popping back out and releasing
that entire charge shot
oh yeah i always forget about that so
yeah you're you're charging it and then
you swim and then you record this okay
yeah that looks great
all right so why don't we show off and
go to the
uh second stage we wanted to show which
is eel tell alley so why don't we cut
away from this
and we'll show that off wait so dutch
what team were you then since we're both
team scissors i'm team rock yeah you are
still dead don't overthink it
all right team paper it is
i feel like you two were fighting over
paper initially and so now you've just
completely changed sides to be true i
mean i'm i'm a fan of big man
it's not really a choice of scissors
it's it's big man
and that's that's probably why i can't
help it
i don't blame you
okay so we're going into eel tail alley
and this is um a different type of stage
oh you know we just saw kind of that
rugged desert uh that dutch was pointing
but this is more of like a cityscape
feel to it yeah right off the bat it's
definitely a different feel let's take a
look around here actually one thing we
should point out too we haven't
mentioned yet was you just spawning
right there and that was one of the new
features as well exactly yeah so you
spawn actually from the air and you can
choose your landing spot as opposed to
always spawning in the same spot
and that
really makes it a little more dynamic
you know maybe you're getting pinned
down in your base but you can actually
choose where to land so that you can
kind of you know approach your your
opponents from a different angle it's
one of the three new techniques with the
other one being squid surge it's a squid
roller and squid spawn i'm seeing a
pattern with these names
about it
let's take a look at the turf map here
we see this is eel tail alley and it
really does look like an alley you know
it's kind of long and narrow
and like an eel like an eel
why am i getting hungry
sushi later yeah it sounds good
so if i'm playing a charger on this map
i'm probably i think it's going to be
all about this this catwalk up here i
think this is where i'm going to be
be living
and that's because i can get you know
the high ground to kind of control this
area down here as the other team comes
up the middle
maybe if i want to get really aggressive
i might come all the way up to
this front area
and be looking down here clear out the
pigeons
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah this spot right here gives me
access you know you've got a clear shot
it's you and all these areas where the
other team might come out
i think there will be a lot of fighting
below too as well and i feel like the
ink vac will be really great because
you'll be able to kind of push the line
push the advance of your team
um using that special exactly yeah you
drop down here you soak up all the ink
that everybody's shooting it takes a
while to charge when there's no ink
it's a little just a little explosion's
a bit smaller too this is why i'm so
excited for this weekend though because
you know like we've been
messing around with this game a little
bit but i'm really excited to get in
there with other people
and uh you know try out all my moves
play nicely with them
nobody against me but
if you see the name dutch on the
opposing team
be afraid
or amazed or impressed all of the above
are the correct responses all right so
this so you got a chance to see the
splat charger and eel tell ali
um let's go ahead and move back to the
lobby because we have one more thing to
show so we're going to cut to that
gave us only the best thing to show i
can't wait i think this is going to be
it's just such a cool feature
um and what we're talking about is we're
going to actually show you one second
the lockers and lockers are just
something i think a lot of people are
wanting you know this customization
option of showing off you know your own
unique style which the splatoon series
has always had um so just being able to
you know expand on that i think it's
wonderful exactly and this is you know
it's all connected to this uh physical
space in the lobby here that's quit
delaying we want lockers now
although we know what's gonna happen
today
uh good this time
[Laughter]
[Music]
so with these person these are personal
lockers and what you can do is you can
actually add uh your weapons and even
some items that you get
from hotlantis that's one of the new
stores um in in this game it's really
cool um on top of that how you're dear
dutch ghosts
oh we can't ever go without it your
closet at home
remember how perfect this was when it
first showed
[Laughter]
oh no you can put the cups upside down
yes
the dust gets in it and stuff so i don't
i mean
also one thing to know is you can yeah
you have stickers um you can actually
even change the color of your locker
there's a lot of stuff to add which is
going to be really really really cool um
one other thing too to point out oh look
what are you done
[Music]
[Laughter]
and you can see other people's lockers
so if you see one that looks something
like this in your travels
hate me all this way it might be duchess
[Laughter]
oh man all right so there's one other
thing too we want to quickly show is the
splash tags which is another really cool
feature um that is also new to the game
all right put that put that mess away
you've done enough
so on the left hand side of the screen
is you'll see it says splat landing with
player one um this is actually the splat
tags where you could normally would have
your name and you can have different
uh banners badges and titles um you
obviously wouldn't just be player one
we'd just use i mean you could be if you
want if you want that's you yeah you are
play you are number one player one no
you're not wrong
[Laughter]
but there's a lot of cool stuff but one
thing to note too is with the lockers
and even the splash tags that there will
be
some season catalogs that come so expect
to have new items uh to be able to put
into your locker and you splash tag
stuff and even some new weapons so
really cool stuff or additional weapons
i should say
so really really cool stuff coming as
well
all right so with that we took a look at
the lockers in the splash tag i have one
more thing i wanted to show
and i got it down here so just give me a
moment to pick it up because i don't
want to drop it and that is the special
edition splatoon 3 nintendo switch
o-l-e-d
super cool it's actually out in stores
august 26th so about now you could go
check it out but we just want to show
that off and let me actually
take this out right here and show you
what the actual system looks like to
outside of its dock it's got this super
super cool design here i'm gonna move a
little back and forth so you can see
that cool little design shimmering
across
and then one more thing i have here i'll
pick this one up this is the splatoon 3
pro controller as well now this one
comes out september 9th so it's not on
launch day but we just wanted to show
you how cool that looks with the two
different colors
and the cool design on it it's so good
it looks awesome i'm gonna end up buying
one and i won't regret it at all
these are super cool
okay so with that being said that is it
for splatoon 3 today um one more time
just to remind everybody at home that
splatoon 3 splatfest world premiere is
going to be out on the eshops now
but don't go anywhere we got some
harvestella up next and we'll see you
soon thanks
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
the splatoon 3 enter the splatlands
invitational 2022 tournament this event
will take place on september 5th at pax
west
some of the top finishers from this
summer splatoon 2 inkopolis showdown
will head to seattle and compete in
north america's first ever splatoon 3
invitational
follow the official nintendo vs twitter
account for updates
[Music]
hi and welcome back to nintendo
treehouse live my name is kay and i'm
here with andrew and amber and we're
going to be taking a look at harvestella
andrew what have we got for people today
so today we're going to be taking a look
at chapter 2 of harvest stella coming to
nintendo's switch as a nintendo switch
uh console exclusive on november 4th and
before we jump into chapter two we're
actually going to show a quick video
highlighting some of the story elements
from chapter one to get us uh on our way
okay look at that
so here we see our main character is
waking up we actually find out that they
have amnesia and i'm not sure where they
are
so they're welcomed by one of the
residents of the town who kind of
explains the situation to them and then
we're introduced to a sea light for the
first time
and all of a sudden the people in the
town are gathering because oh no a giant
crystal element is falling towards the
earth oh no the planet it's pretty
dangerous
oh when it crashed oh boy but what do we
do when there's a crashed crystal we
investigate it of course and then while
we're investigating it we actually find
someone that we bring back to our home
the mysterious person
and
you know start talking about where they
could be from
and then eventually they run off
which leads us to uh
the person who greeted us with our
amnesia are actually showing us the
importance of harvesting and farming and
how that actually plays into the story
which we'll talk a little bit more as
we're going through chapter two and
that's very cool to give you a farm so
you could have some goals to work toward
as you try to remember who you are right
yeah
so then we're introduced to the canyon
which is just north of our home and we
meet deontas
after speaking with deontas we find out
that we actually have kind of similar
goals and they join our party so we'll
be able to play alongside dances in
chapter two
great that brings us up to speed yeah
we're gonna actually jump into some game
play
yeah and i'm here i just started in my
house i just woke up and i'm about to go
uh farm some crops that i planted the
previous day
um
so let's go check those out and see how
they're doing oh your farm is so cute
amber thank you so much so i planted
some of these dress lettuce and it looks
like they're ready to harvest so i'm
gonna pick all of these
let's go yeah
so yummy there we go and then i also
have some carob seeds so i'm gonna plant
some more seeds too so they're gonna be
ready for the next day
once i harvest all of these crops and
not harvest sorry once i've planted all
these i'm going to water them oh my god
oh my gosh can we take a look at this
though like
look at how cute this like watering wand
is it's it's so cute and very convenient
very high fantasy very fast too yeah
yeah yeah very efficient i'm loving it i
also love the name of the crops they had
carobs i had some carrots yup and i have
some stellar wheat seeds over here as
well all these crops
take a little bit of different time i
believe my carobs will only take one day
so i should be able to pick them
tomorrow and put them in this
chest here or my shipping box and at the
end of the day i'll actually make money
from the things that i put in this chest
so
great perks of farming but it's also
important to note that obviously making
money off of your crops is important
because it allows you to to purchase
things in in the shops in the stores but
you can also use some of the vegetables
that you harvest and the fruit to
cook exactly exactly and so what i'm
going to do right now is i'm going to go
back up to the canyon up here and go
explore a little bit more with deanthus
try to find my friend but i can also go
and defeat monsters to get seeds so this
is going to help me more with my farming
making sure that i'm still making lots
of money too so i can live this
fantastic farming lifestyle that i need
yeah so as amber said our main goal
right now is to go deeper into the
canyon and find our friend who we're
looking for with dianthus but as you'll
see on the screen time is a very
important part of this game and so when
you start in the morning it's about 6
a.m and you know every day you have your
main goals to go forward to but it's a
really good idea to start by harvesting
your crops planting things so at the end
of the day you can go back and see it
and then um you know continue to level
up and get money as you progress with
the game
yeah it's running into some baddies
already
all right took them down with some
defenders yeah
it's important to keep an eye too on
your um health and stamina which you can
see in the bottom left side of the
screen the little yellow bar on the
bottom is your stamina bar and as you
perform actions like farming and or even
attacking or even running yeah that uses
up some of your stamina now you have
next to that also you have your little
stomach meter and we mentioned earlier
cooking you can you can make meals for
yourself to restore health and stamina
and to fill up that stomach meter and as
long as you have food in your stomach
your stamina will regenerate
automatically
and as amber continues through this area
we're seeing that the map on the top
right actually uh finds the new areas
so everything starts off as black then
as you explore you see more and more hey
guys i found this really beautiful
waterfall and it's pretty refreshing i
think we should take a break sure we've
already been adventuring we farmed a lot
this morning let's take a little bit of
a break
live your best life i know right
oh and my health and stamina have been
replenished that's great but it did take
some time it did take some time but i
think it's smart to make sure that we're
taking a break every now and then
all right i'm gonna go up this hill area
up here
can we just appreciate how pretty this
place is too it's gorgeous but look at
that i also found a broken ladder up
here
can you fix that i
let's go try to find some from down here
not from down there
i want to i want to get up there
there was also another broken ladder
over here that i found previously when i
found deanthus and so i'm hoping to find
that one as well so we can repair it
maybe have some fun shortcuts throughout
this uh
canyon oh here we go
let me talk about dancers for a second i
love the hair her hair is so long and
the shoe the shoes though
she's just fabulous very fabulous so
we found this broken ladder
deanthus is actually going to help me
repair this ladder
so when you are repairing things it's
actually going to also take time
outside of your day to repair
any of these things so making sure that
you're you have enough time to repair
them but also get back to your house is
really important so let's see repairing
this ladder is going to take an
hour it's early it's still early we
still have time we still have time you
do have to keep an eye on the clock
though because if you're out too late um
and you run out of stamina you'll
actually collapse and be sent back home
exactly oh here's another shiny what's
this what is it what's
a mushroom
all right can you trust the mushrooms on
the ground i'm gonna eat it it feels
pleasant it smells pleasant yeah just
brush it off
what could go wrong nothing it's like
vitamin bitter stuff
[Music]
my stamina okay well good thing i have a
sandwich from my friend chris who can
help me i'm going to eat this sandwich
it's going to help
replenish my health actually healed the
anthes too oh yes exactly so it's a good
immense oh good
that's a good thing
you can see that dianthus is doing more
of those long range attacks yeah
probably because of the high heels you
know but
that's great
let's see what we got all around here i
think you can also see as amber runs
around that she's picking things up off
the side of the road yes
inedible mushroom but but things like
crafting materials and other ingredients
that you can use in cooking or things
that you can sell
along with your crops to make money yeah
i think she just found some seeds
actually and sometimes some seeds yeah
oh there's so many guys here let's get
them use some of your skills amber i did
i just used one where i was spinning
around but we'll see if i can
[Music]
nice
awesome oh my god uni onion seeds some
copper ore awesome i'm getting lots of
good stuff you are making out like a
bandit oh yeah
what's also helpful is the top right map
has that orange arrow that also points
to in the main objective so it will help
us find our friend that we're looking
for exactly there are a lot of
interesting and important things marked
on the map you can see once you find
them the gathering points where you have
to come back later and continue to find
materials out in the wild
oh
look at that hit there we go that's what
i'm talking about okay great work thank
you thank you you're making this look
easy
[Music]
yeah get him deanthus
nice
okay good job i love the scenery and i
didn't talk about earlier but right now
it's spring and the seasons play a
really important part of the story so
what we're seeing now as we go into
summer fall winter and the quietest and
the season of death uh that will also
change what we're seeing in the colors
and everything as well got some hard
stone just trying to gather as many
resources as possible i don't know what
i want to make sure i can get everything
oh something
shiny yes shiny oh no we've lost her you
can't eat this though so it's good right
okay i'm gonna reach into the bush and
get this what is this
this is like the most obvious bait
you've ever seen
come on
oh
all right i got them though okay
all right let's see
there we go wow
yeah got him no problem got him
that poor goblin i wanted to protect
it's shiny
this is my shiny
all right let's get these guys these
baddies
[Music]
all right
here
we
go
oh i know
look at all this
more lumber too i'm getting so many
goodies
i can't wait to go back home and uh
plant all these oh and here's this on
the second fridge we're looking for a
ladder
yeah oh okay this is gonna consume one
hour
okay
we're getting the important thing about
these ladders is obviously as you can
see these these dungeon areas are quite
large and it does take more than one day
to get through them so being able to
build shortcuts with the ladders like
this helps you progress farther in the
dungeon without wasting as much time
on the areas you've already explored and
i think i just saw on the map that we
were getting kind of close to the next
section of the canyon so maybe since
it's getting late it might be a good
idea to head back yeah and i noticed
that there was a fishing spot here
earlier so i think i might stop and just
fish for just a little bit
i suppose we have we have time
but
and look at how peaceful it is and we
can sit here and listen to the music for
a little bit too
reflect on the adventures from the day
exactly i hope there are fish count all
of our bounties yeah i hope there are
fish
it does take time
can be quite time consuming but you do
get some good stuff from it again things
that you can chip for money or sometimes
things you can use in recipes to make
different types of meals for yourself
and your friends exactly exactly oh come
on fishy fishy please i don't think
they're biting today
maybe we're being a little bit too noisy
maybe i was a little too noisy
let's give another couple seconds and
maybe head back maybe
oh there you go awesome okay
oh wow a lot of salmon
nice i love the art the art scheme is so
good all the fish look really cool and
the the meals and the character art
and also this thing that i'm using right
now is a return bell it's something that
i can craft and return immediately to my
farm so if i'm further out in the canyon
than i want to be and i need to return
home quick it's a great item to use to
get back to your home really quickly
um
i'm going to go back outside of my farm
and just
try to
get a few more crops in here right you
did pick up some seeds didn't you yeah i
did i picked up a lot of seeds
um and depending on what you plant it
might be ready tomorrow when you wake up
oh yeah so my carob seeds i think only
take one day so those will be ready for
me tomorrow
and then i can make some more money
but i think we got some uni onion seeds
we got a couple different things so i'd
like to plant those just to make sure
that we have a good variety of stuff so
let's let's plant these you need onion
seeds i'm gonna plant them right in the
middle why not
chaos chaos
and then we're gonna surround them with
some duress lettuce because you know
what why not
and then we're gonna bring out our handy
dandy
watering tool i love this watering tool
i know i can't get over it it's so good
i'm just admiring how nice the music is
now that it's nighttime it's so peaceful
and look at how beautiful our farm is
just the aesthetic of this game oh so
pretty gorgeous
well let me just dump all this stuff
into um
into the shipping box we got that
crystal and it looks like it's going to
earn me a lot of money when shipped so
let's send that out
maybe some of these berries
and the fur oh yeah let's ship that fur
all right
and then open up our storage box let's
store some of this stuff because i don't
think i'll need it for a while
yeah
you know onions and things yeah i just
store some stuff
all right just get out of my inventory
all right all right
and now it's getting close to night time
you have time to craft another belt
probably a good idea it's a smart idea
just to make sure i have them yeah
because i know how late you like to be
exploring
how late i like to be up fishing exactly
yeah that's what really happened
and it is good to note also that when
you're crafting at home it also takes
time just a little bit of time yes well
depending on what you make yeah it could
take longer too
awesome yay my return fell so pretty
yeah
hey amber it's almost nine o'clock it's
almost nine o'clock time for bed
all right well let's just take our time
your house is really i know here i'm
just going to do a little
quick pan oh look how cute and homey
this little house is i'm so glad that
they
let us stay here yeah gave us this farm
they're just like here this house is
just here you can take it yeah
oh and you leveled up level up so
running around and beating all those
baddies helped so got some uh physical
tag magic all the good stuff and then
here's our shipments wow we gotta see
how much money i made too much money
look at all that look at all that i know
this calls for a shopkin
so we can go into town um after i
harvest and of course water some of my
plants
morning chores my morning chores exactly
but then i'll go back into the or i'll
go into the village and then we can go
look around there and maybe i'm on a
shopping spree yeah yeah let's do it as
long as we just go back and make sure we
find our friend
that's that's the most important thing
for shopping
but first shopping well and you can find
a bunch of interesting things at the
shop you know obviously things for your
farm more seeds but they also have some
equipment that you can use for
adventuring as well so yeah
oh yay my carob seeds are all ready wow
awesome look at all these ready back
there too those are so cute they look
like little bunnies but they do look
like little bunny and tasty
oh and looks like my wheat is also ready
as well
oh wow
i have so much stuff
the chemicals are great too because they
grow quickly they sell for they sell
fibers
yeah but they also give you a little bit
of health and a little bit of they fill
your food meter a little bit if you're
eating them as a snack while you're out
on the uh on the road
got a lot of uses their ingredients and
in a couple different recipes i think i
have some more wheat seeds so let's
replant these just to make sure that i
still have some stuff growing
gotta maintain this farm
nice thing i think that the stores in
town open at 8 a.m yes so i have enough
time in the morning to get my chores
done all right
i think we have some time to grow some
more yeah let's grow some more dressed
lettuce
[Music]
there we go
and it's so calming
yeah the music on the farm is just
really great nice and relaxing so
peaceful you almost forget the the
imminent danger you're in
exactly
oh all right so let's drop these off in
our shipping box and then we're gonna go
run to the village and i'm gonna sprint
there
thank you
all oh good thing i got some sandwiches
so i think i'll be fine
that is definitely a playstyle
[Laughter]
yeah eat everything a sprint everywhere
so this is the village of leafy yes and
i love it's it's so beautiful it's so
pretty it has a sea light in the back
around you can see right there pink
and it's really cool because the first
time we're introduced to this village
there's no one here and i won't explain
why you know you have to play to find
out but
it's really nice to see it lively with
all the different residents from the
town yeah and there's also a couple
fishing spots
this is our general store so let's go in
here and see what we can do for our
shopping spree
other places
there are
a smitty where you can upgrade your
weapons and there's a place where you
can get upgrades for your house and your
farm too exactly
and here's oh so we got a fireproof ring
and a defense ring oh okay oh that's a
big spindle
well you didn't make a lot of money
overnight hello
did you see this backpack over here ten
thousand uh i i am not rolling it out if
it's a good backpack it's worth it it's
worth it and oh look our friend cress is
here too
looks like she's buying some stuff as
well
yeah okay as you said too there's a
couple other shops too even the doctor
that you can go visit in the town so
there's a lot of other things too for
you to go do but
i really want to make sure my friend's
okay yeah but before you want to waste
too much time yeah before we do that
let's equip this ring so we already have
one ring equipped yeah i already have
one ring equipped that's a simple magic
swordsman ring but i'm gonna
equip this defense ring i think that'll
help me
while i'm fighting some of these baddies
off to go find your friend yes
come on deanthes let's go
as you can see as she travels on the map
the time actually moves a bit quicker
while you're on the world map so you
have to be very careful and don't be
like me and get all turned around and
waste half a day just trying to find
where you're going next don't do that
don't do that be smart
make good choices
okay it's already 10 30. let's
rush in here and try to find our friend
so you should be able to use those
ladders that you're progressing right
exactly that's what i'll be looking for
so
the first one that we repaired
right here
beautiful
that's very very good very convenient
right very convenient very sturdy ladder
these guys are back audience
they don't learn you are almost out of
stamina dear oh i was running too much
give any more of the sandwiches left i
do have a lot of sandwiches
[Music]
oh there we go i'm going to eat one more
now you could well oh look at that
your stamina would have regenerated but
it will continue to regenerate longer
now
yeah so once i have my when uh your
stomach is full help replenish some of
that a little bit quicker yeah
[Music]
come on deanthes help me out here's this
back there
yeah nice job
that's teamwork
[Music]
thank you thank you she's so good
get some more fur that's a great ally
yeah more copper ore
oh my gosh look at all these baddies god
i love the music in here too
music is so beautiful and it changes
whether you're at your home or in the
village or in the middle of battle it's
all just so different and really cool
come on dantes
there we go i got him
and here is
our other ladder that we went the long
way though i did end up going a long way
i wanted to gather all i wanted to fight
some more guys
well thank
to do some little extra little fighting
over here
ooh and look at all these things berries
blueberry
that's a cool berry better than uncool
berry
oh feeling something unusual ahead let's
let's go i hope we can find our friend
[Music]
oh
isn't it beautiful
i love it
that structure i know so
um deanthes and i are going to be
wandering around and we noticed some of
these structures that um
seem a little bit out of place
exactly so
and they shouldn't exist here but it's
all a big history a big mystery but
another mystery
speaking of misspeaking of so we also
run into this
magnificent
uh unicorn oh my goodness um he is
looking uh for
a princess
also looking very fly oh he looks very
fly i like his hair
oh and he calls us an impertinent
buffoon
you know just
friendly
very friendly a very friendly guy
rude talking about some princess yes so
he's this uh corned creature he's
looking for a princess we're also
looking for someone but
he thinks we're hiding the princess from
him or or perhaps hunting the prince or
maybe trying to find her but we're not
hiding her but there's no
we have no convincing him that we are
not hiding
his princess
and we yeah we're also searching for a
girl
he just doesn't want to listen to us at
all
a giant unicorn horn isn't i know he's
hearing
yeah he he wants to know there's no he's
not he's not going to take any of this
so
witness me
so
he wants to fight me oh no
well good luck thank you i've never
fought a unicorn before
[Laughter]
come on deanthes let's
good thing go ate those sandwiches
earlier so my stamina is all good your
health is kind of shaky but oh i think
i'll be fine i got it i got this
oh my goodness oh my gosh hectianthus
this you got this oh no i watch out for
that ring watch out
okay okay okay all right you're hanging
in there
i don't want to wait for those i want
you to charge back up i know i want my
power
you're almost there though okay really
close where are you
oh no oh no
your skill's ready all right let's get
him
oh oh he got you away yeah
oh there you go i was trying to do this
but that was a little closer
closer than i thought it would be don't
worry he uh lost love his health right
yeah we beat him
and he's impressed famous last words
witness me
and
look at this beautiful guy oh no oh no i
spoke too soon i'm sorry
well i mean we still have sandwiches
left right i know i have a few
sandwiches uh
yeah so
i'm trembling in his presence so he
still wants to know where his princess
is but
i think if we take some more time to
explain to him exactly what's going on
who we are looking for that he will
hopefully he'll understand
maybe you can clear up this
misunderstanding let's see
he doesn't seem prone to listen no
and also
the princess and our friend have
different names so i think that's number
one for us to obviously you know they're
not the same person
but let's see if he'll come with us i
think he'd be a a good party member you
know i'd like some
healing i think he's a little bit too
stingy for that but oh maybe he might be
able to help us out another way
or maybe he'll just you know be annoying
just just look pretty rude
[Laughter]
helpful somehow yeah somehow maybe we'll
find out we'll we'll find out
awesome
nice let's go deeper into the camera
turn with us
yeah let's keep looking and try to find
our friend it's only one o'clock so
you've got lots of time lots of time
[Music]
the music is so beautiful
oh it's so pretty
so this right here
this is a mono light
these are actually save points um and
teleport points for you so when you go
and activate these um
one obviously you could save your your
progress here which is great but also
you can teleport to different points of
the map but then you could also go back
to your farm so it's another great place
to
move and get back home when you need to
if it's getting too late so well and
it's another great way to progress
farther into a dungeon exactly exactly
when you have to go home and sleep
there's another fishing spot right there
so many stuff going to go fish i'm going
to say i'm that you don't use those to
find your favorite fishing spot
you are exhibiting great restraint and i
am i'm trying for you guys
[Laughter]
oh look at this a bridge
i'm sure deanthes can help us fix this
[Music]
good old deandis yeah
what's wrong this time
she doesn't have to be happy about it
all right i know
just a little help please just a little
but props to her for fixing that in
those heels oh yeah
um i mean she's making you do it uh so i
guess
it's so quick to give her a credit
but now we got a repair kit but we also
got a repair kit recipe which i'm
looking forward to to go
make more of these kits and then see
what else i can go repair
it's probably a good idea to have kits
ready before you go on adventures
exactly so you don't get stuck two or
three you know yeah but this one like
the
the latter previously will take an hour
to repair
um so we're at 2 30 p.m that's fine we
have plenty of time still and let's see
if we can find our friend what is that i
don't know i want to fight it though
different from the other enemies we saw
that monster all right
you're ready
i i am ready i'm ready to jump in let's
go
so this monster deanthes is letting me
know has a thicker hide and so our melee
attacks aren't going to be as useful
against it and we need to use magic if
only we could use magic if only i could
use magic unicorns
that uh you can do it yeah so our
unicorn friend is going to try to teach
us here grumble grumble
please my magic my please mr unicorn
please
crumble
oh come on please
all right very well professor unicorn
class is about to begin you'd better
listen let's go
[Music]
fancy wow
now you try it
go ahead yeah just like that
how am i supposed to do that
you can't tell by watching he's so funny
i love his dialogue
[Music]
one mustn't bulk at the first hurdle
amber
[Laughter]
i can do this so you're closing your
eyes now to see if that helps and it
does oh
my magic
[Music]
oh
i can know
amazing
now i can use magic i am really excited
about this mage shop class is one of my
favorites yes
all right
well
let's see what we can do against that
baddie then
[Music]
all right
i want to use my magic yes we can let's
go let's do it let's do this
yeah let's keep moving this
but before i
get going and fighting him i do need to
select this job really quick you can
normally do this on a monolith or you
can only do this on a monolith but
just for tutorial purposes it's allowing
me to
change the mage class right now
all right so
we're changing
to the mage look at how i love your
outfit change too i know so good
oh my goodness
that was extremely effective extremely
wow yeah
we're so strong guys check that out
oh i just yeah i love it
magic
so i know we have to go further into the
canyon to find our friend but uh it's
almost three o'clock so maybe we should
call it a day for now yeah i think so
too because i also got more stuff to go
uh
plant
water yeah everything i get those carobs
and you got to spend some time fishing
let's be honest
i mean i didn't want to say it but
and with that i'm actually going to use
my return bell here to go back home
[Music]
awesome safe and sound safe and sound
exactly
great um so we'll actually stop there
for today but before we end um we
actually have a special video from
goshina who's the composer of
harvestella so let's take a look at that
[Music]
all right so that's all the time we have
today to show you harvestello we hope
you enjoyed what we had to show
um the game is available for pre-order
now on nintendo eshop and it will
release on november 4th i hope you're
all looking forward to it as much as we
are
thanks for tuning in and we will see you
next time
[Music]
you